The biggest difference
between TV games and
mobile games is how players
interact with them.
Instead of using a touch screen,
players control Android TVs using
remote controls or game controllers.
There are two basic types.
The first is a D-pad or directional pad.
This is the basic style of remote
control that most Android TVs ship with.
For that reason,
it's very important to design for.
Just like the controllers
you may have used as a kid,
it's important to realize that none of
these buttons are pressure sensitive.
So pressing harder won't make
your car accelerate any faster.
This is a game controller.
Of course, the biggest difference
with remote control is the joysticks.
Whereas you can think of the buttons
on the D-pad as basically being on and
off, the joysticks, of course,
have a range of motion.
In addition,
Android TV games can also be controlled
using devices connected via
the nearby connections API.
This let's players use their phone or
tablet as a second screen input device.
This opens up very cool options for
multi screen gaming.
You can imagine that if you have friends
over to your house to play a game,
you don't necessarily have to purchase
additional game controllers for
them, they can simply use the phones
they already have in their pockets.
Check out the video in
the instructor notes to learn more.
Let's talk a bit about
designing your control scheme.
First, always plan for a D-pad,
this control set is the default for
Android TV.
At a minimum, you should at least be
able to navigate your menus this way.
Even if your game is best
played with a game controller,
make sure players can gracefully exit
it through your menus using a D-pad.
That said,
it's best to support both D-pads and
game controllers in your game,
whenever possible.
Be explicit about what kinds of
controllers your game works best with.
Do this both in your
Google Play description and
when your game starts up.
A good strategy is to detect at runtime
what types of controllers are connected
and then prompt players if
they're not an ideal type.
This sets expectations properly and
maximizes your chances of getting
a good rating on Google Play.
It's good practice to show
visual controller instructions.
If you do so, be sure the images
you use are free from branding.
Down the road,
it may be possible to detect what brands
of controllers are detected at runtime,
and show matching graphics for them but
for right now, please use this template.
You can find this image, and
more like it, by following
the link in the instructor notes.
Here are three tips for
designing your control scheme.
Start with default controls that
are in line with what users expect
in different regions.
For example,
if you plan to release both in Japan and
the United States, make sure you set the
defaults appropriately for each region.
When possible, the back button
should always work as expected.
Usually, it should navigate backward,
bread crumb style through the previous
screens the player has been on.
For example,
if the user is playing your game and
presses back,
you might take them to the pause screen.
If they press back again,
you might take them to your game's
home screen and if they press it yet
again, take them all the way back
to the Android TV home screen.
Because TV remote controls though have
a limited number of buttons, it's also
appropriate to use the back button to
bring up a context menu in your game.
If you choose to do so though, make
it clear how to move back from there.
Last, don't rely on special buttons.
Not all controllers have start,
search or menu buttons, for example.
You can learn more about
best practices by following
the link in the instructor notes.